hi there Steve Kaufman here today first
of all it's a sunny day the Sun is
coming in through my window ah it's a
great day here in Vancouver we've had
some pretty wet and cool weather for the
last little while Steve Kaufman here and
my blog is the linguist on language and
I talk about things related to languages
and particularly language learning today
my theme is what does it cost to learn a
language and I was doing a lot of
thinking about this today because today
I ordered my iPad so some of you may
think that's a real extravagance it with
all the whatever else they sold me on
the website is seven hundred and some
dollars which is a lot of money because
I already have a blackberry so I don't
need it for my communication and I'm
buying it primarily for reading and
language learning this is going to be my
language my language lab my portable
language lab where I will be able to
access all the content I want in
different languages and import it into
link and save words and phrases and
review them in flashcards and listen to
content in fact do all the things that I
do to learn languages 700 and some odd
dollars today I received here a freebie
handout from Simon Fraser University
here in Vancouver and continuing
education here you know here's the front
page okay now I don't know why they
always put attractive people attractive
people's faces on brochures it must be
discriminating against old geezers like
me they always have young fresh
attractive faces on these brochures
nevertheless I look up their language
area and here we have English alright
immersion English full time 3-month
immersion English $4,200 for three
months 25 hours a week
twenty-five hours a day for three months
now what's that person going to learn in
three months for $4,200 and if that
person travels from some foreign country
and stays with a host family in
Vancouver which also costs a lot of
money and in many cases the host family
is not even english-speaking but that's
another issue $4,200
here's another thing I was thinking of
because I was reflecting on my spending
750 dollars for an iPad I thought to
myself if I travel to Russia and at the
school there cost four thousand two
hundred dollars per month and I added in
my flight to Russia and wherever I'm
going to stay in whatever accommodation
it would be an awful lot of money I do
want to go to Russia but I'll go there
and travel around have a good time
speaking of Russian I was in Tucson it
comes in three years ago before I
started studying Russian at link I went
in the University Bookstore and all
these university bookstores are
phenomenal like shopping centers where
they sell you everything from t-shirts
to sporting goods but they also have
great shelves of textbooks that the
professor's require people to buy these
textbooks aren't cheap I was looking
around for books on Russian because they
weren't very many here in Vancouver and
all he had was a thing called political
Russian which is this book I've had the
book for three years it is a completely
useless book it has perhaps 5% of it
consists of political sort of texts that
I could find in any newspaper on the web
today and then it has a bunch of you
know reading exercises pretext
background this report about National
Security Advisor Condoleezza Rice well
we can get that somewhere else we don't
need it here very little they don't have
a gloss
in fact I have never used the book it
was $80 this cost $80 out the window and
I gather from talking to people that
it's quite common to spend more than
$100 a semester on textbooks that's a
lot of money so my iPad you know and I
think of my iPad and I think of when I
really got keen on language learning the
late in my career I mean I've always had
an interest in languages and I've
learned that but I got really fired up
when I was 55 and I wanted to learn
Cantonese living here in Vancouver and I
discovered the minidisc player and I
thought that was a revolution and since
that time which is about a little less
than 10 years ago we've had the minidisc
player followed by the mp3 we've of
course had an explosion in what's
available on the Internet in terms of
content newspapers magazines novels
language learning podcasts you name it a
whole gamut of things link of course and
then we've moved from the simple mp3
player to the iPod to the whole
development of iTunes iTunes U and now
we have iPad and we have literally
thousands of people creating apps for
every possible use including language
learning for these tools and that's just
in it in a period of ten years and yet
at the universities very little has
changed they still have their lectures
they still like here at Simon Fraser
they want to charge a four thousand two
hundred dollars for three months of
English in the classroom learning here
in Vancouver I mean if I went to I don't
care Bucharest Romania to learn Romanian
for three months I wouldn't spend five
hours a day in a classroom and I sure
wouldn't spend $4,200 for the privilege
of doing so I would listen I would read
I would make friends I would travel
around but of course as many of you know
I would do a lot of work before
I went there and all of that can be done
again by the internet using iPod iPad
mp3 player you name it and so forth so
nothing's changed the universities are
still charging this they're still
charging a fortune for textbooks like
this and I looked up on the internet and
what happens if you take a course and
buy the textbook that the professor said
you had to take and then you decided not
to continue with the course well I think
within one month you can sell it back or
something then at the end of the year
you can sell it back as long as the
professor is still recommending that
textbook and as long as the textbook
publisher hasn't come up with a you know
a new edition which makes yours obsolete
in the best of cases you can sell it
back for 50% otherwise is 25% out
otherwise it's zero so this is just
money spent and wasted because what do
you need the textbook for I mentioned on
my blog Amazon sent me an email and they
said that here's this because they keep
track of what I'm interested in they
said here's this book for learning
Chinese a Chinese kaleidoscope a
collection of newspaper and magazine
articles compiled by no less than four
authors for professors to compile
newspaper and magazine articles that are
already out of date they're no longer
current presumably they have some
explanations they're probably a lot of
grammatical explanations that everyone
reading that book has already been
through and still can't remember and it
probably doesn't help them very much
fifty dollars for that book fifty
dollars so you know that kind of
triggered all this interest so people
wasting is fortunate on textbooks
newspaper magazine articles I can have
every not every but tens of if not
hundreds of Chinese newspaper and
magazine articles at my fingertips I can
read them with an online dictionary I
can save the words and phrases that link
and presumably other systems I can put
them on Anke review them in flashcards
I can find people on the Internet
talk to native speakers what am I going
to do with the $50 textbook which
probably only has you know 20 chapters
20 little articles it's amazing so
everything else has changed in the last
ten years we've gone from thee when I
was first studying language we have the
open reel tape recorder went to
cassettes went the CDs went to mini disc
players mp3 players iPod iPad all that
has changed but we're still asking
students to spend 50 or 100 or 150
dollars on textbooks and we're still
charging as in the case of Simon Fraser
$4,200 for a three-month intensive
course in English with no guarantee that
the person graduating from that course
will have improved their English
significantly or at least not to the
tune of $4,200 thanks for listening